not that I booted in Discovery with my
mama we should we should all of us work
and not speak well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we're talking with dr. Igor a charc
offski who is the father of the water
birth method and a physician from Moscow
dr. Jurkowski can you tell us something
about the water birth method because
it's an ammonium which a mere $2 DNA of
idea it is practically nobody or now has
got a lot of information about it
although it is gradually becoming more
in bappa a normal baby who's experienced
water births can swim let us say the
ocean very easily interpreted ski wooden
associate walk after a adapt Tirana
cried Lucy employing social and a baby
it is practically a sea creature who is
better adapted to live in the water than
us it is no cat or any process path of
naivete unknown as possible and attached
Lady Catherine diadem or a Grom they are
cold need to heat evening very or a
physics class molester and such a baby
is not only adapted to the sea into the
water but it is also adapted to the
giant occult properties revealed by
water and the world ocean the exact
duplicate the Bible says us that the
stairs on the whales I can say that such
sea creatures as whales day reveal us a
lot of hidden knowledge in our evolution
the first water birds have been taking
place together with the dolphins and my
initial idea what was that dolphins were
very necessary for this kind word
religions like Christianity they are
also founded on similar similar
information so normally I think children
should be submerged into the water and
then to swim with the dolphins
so that's practically every everyone
every of them good to swim hundreds of
miles so this is not simply a matter of
creating a less traumatic birth for
infant and mother this is more mysticism
of water itself a kind of religion of
the aqueous dimension is that right let
us begin with that the humanity the
human species in general nowadays is
mentally disturbed the cataleya searches
to Dani practice the caste rule I would
hope if is each give us what institution
Bieber's methodology that we've got
nowadays they they are very likely to
castrate mentally the persons are being
born and if we take normal children
after what a birth being born under
water being society did a lot and is
constantly doing a lot in order to
destroy the unique abilities that have
been revealed by way of this of this
water birth a child having experienced
water birth practices a sort of
pranayama one can see
it can hold its breath for several
minutes and I would like to point out
the Russian clairvoyant and research at
Silcox key wrote in the beginning of the
century that children after water bus
could develop their clairvoyant
abilities and develop the potentialities
of their brain currently Chikatilo lies
dead and vada in usability of our most
accession Ambala see only animals giving
birth under the water they live about
three times longer than the so-called
normals and their brain is usually
bigger
I mean primarily rabbits critical role
in rabbits so do you believe that this
is the original method of human birth
and that somehow we lost this practice
through history and now must regain it
is that your notion undoubtedly and the
human species like any other species
existing now on the ground on the earth
they've got a history that includes also
the water existence our civilization
constantly destroys the great ability is
giving by the truth having been given to
the children by nature for instance I
can say that children are four five six
months then can may they can make
mountain climbing they can jump easy
differences from this particular table
and then can reveal various other
incredible things so obviously your
method of birth is not widely used are
you an optimistic person in terms of the
human situation or are you feeling
pessimistic as we approach the next
twenty years ago that Boris even of
predicted that by the second millennium
it will be about 60% of American babies
who will be delivered by means of water
bus Monica's autopsy list and the ado
mr. Americans a new spirit that the
minitek be destroyed it proved to be
optimist I'm not sure that the Americans
could proceed so speedily so rapidly
mr. buney will attack you slowly Akaka
united Catherine medallion an RCT 30
attacks it messes most anybody sleepy
destroyers but a monster
probably the Americans could have been
more rapid if they could have had
something like the Holocaust that he we
have experienced and the Soviet system
after these years now there have been a
lot of cases when mother's waiting
babies they were really irradiated 30
years before Chernobyl for instance in
the Republic of Kazakhstan so for many
of them this attempt of giving water
birth was like an attempt to give a
better future for their babies who were
very probable to be already sick and for
instance I have myself experienced a lot
of premature births because of these
disturbances caused by a negative
influence of radiation and of similar
factors and it was my idea to take these
show these children these babies into
the liquid surrounding and then this way
to try to save them remember the topic
of our conference the theme of
is restless I firmly believe that there
are such cases when babies have been
hexed and my impression is that one
shouldn't supply energy for them and
this state but quite directly opposite
one should slow down the processes their
energetic balance to take them out of
this negative state in a slow way now
the rate of survival of children being
held under water is much higher than the
rate of survival of babies and nor a
so-called normal conditions it has been
shown by a number of physiological
studies and for instance if the babies
have already got some disturbances
primarily hard disturbances I would say
that water births or just spending a lot
of time and the water is equal for them
was for instance the massage of the
heart the direct massage it is really
producing incredible results and I think
that by means of contraction of the
veins and the arteries and the
corresponding changes and the blood one
can produce sort of another heart of
another physiological organ inside the
body
created by means of the of new Nedim we
had no most loveliest of ludica Tory now
who did well if she eats is that over
but obviously it's a very cooler
now the main problem is that the mother
and the people attending to this they
should be normal and they should be very
positive to this kind of treatment and a
lifestyle because very frequently for
instance if the hand is desperately
worried about her child the chicken can
die because of this particular anguish I
to the beyblades engine female surgeon
FINA blood that language machine and
polemic I've done clock period psychotic
skits private industry
tzedakah though Anna Anna might what
personal rights it will show me bruising
Kotori pursue it internationally a
fantasy I would call such kind of things
evolutionary neurosis which paralyzes a
lot of positive abilities the baby and
this is why I tend to use to reduce to
recur to the help of dolphins have got a
wonderful energetic field it must have
been very difficult for you as a kind of
visionary and mystic to spread these
sorts of ideas inside a social system
that was so largely materialistic has it
been easier for you since the changes in
the Soviet era
I have I have to tell you that there is
a great lot of mystics and mystical and
minded people in Russia and they have
been constantly working all the time
probably they were unable to produce as
many books or there is other materials
as in the West but this hidden culture
has been very very very active in my
country I will tell you quite frankly
about my problems for instance I came to
the West and I submerge the baby under
the water and then I freeze it for 24
hours
and then I put a thermometer into his
rectal rectal how do you call it rectal
rectum rectum
yes and I take his temperature and it is
5 degrees lower than normal and then you
understand very well that the doctors
attending to debate very much against
goujian previous la france apart nia
Kotori most probably stoichiometric yeah
Picazo i need for by Elysee the history
I've brought a one-year-old child
one-year-old baby to France I could at
the time swim about 60 miles
and they were my impression isn't it
were they were simply afraid of the baby
and it is not registered anywhere you
points the Arabic values night deletes
it veered Italian Parma machine even
your ideal in this list for instance the
Japanese have got quite enough
information during the last 30 years but
I don't know about a single case of
water birth in Japan during this time we
did Fitness Italy at this Dalek news
when he had not yet Canyon de la vie de
rodillas Linnaean grad vehicle even came
in grant context good technique a
technique for diodes in India Docks
grade what Varma will never get over
there is a special book written and
Swedish and that you can buy everywhere
and there is a lot of information about
what a bus by the sweets and I know
about only one case and that was my
woman who emigrated to Sweden from
Russia so this is the the occult the
occult life of the worst witches very
well developed but still there are
immediately the cases them to the United
States because this was a toast about a
new jet lavage I generally brunette my
Guineans in our ocean planet sistema tax
rate below a public Ivana Etna crud
Messiah via national audience a mobile
provide Killam III is a product that the
provider is quite enough information
being published and produced by mass
media in the United States that children
can swim several miles in a row and
there is a methodology of teaching them
to swim yet normal Argentinian I know
doesn't hide yet about bhujette [ __ ] I
don't know a single case and all the
United States a single baby who would
have been taught this methodology what
kind of a world would we have if
everyone had been born according to
methods I wouldn't call that my
methodology just primarily Inuvialuit in
evolutionary methodology one could say
that a baby has already got hidden
knowledge about the trauma that is
waiting for him because of the
gravitation during the birth and so it
doesn't develop develop the brain and
it's capacitors but more considered
program is that clock is regarded as
imminent a Roselli serum a greenish
energy is a grayish the Morse code so
the program is that the babies should be
born with smaller brain smaller heads I
would say this human species simply had
to come to a some sense of the word
because we don't use the bit and the
bigger part of our rest which is water
would gravity seems to be the problem
here would birth in the weightlessness
of space be the equivalent to water
birth no it wouldn't be equivalent
producing our space programs we have
made it giant giant Holocaust of our
culture the best of our science and a
general of our well idea check when you
lose any ideas there's not space basic
biblioteca and the water you don't need
clothes you don't need all these
libraries it'll be no question mr. Freud
stay in DVD it's the approach versus the
studio catherine again generating lists
and looks into the past of its species
ammonia domestic what the derogatory
shekel I get scared when I texted civil
is that such a great planet doesn't mean
at all this huge civilization which is
gradual which is all the time producing
ecological catastrophe the daily check
our our bomb techs gates the jiho's look
at upward so what is the movie star
taxing such a such a baby doesn't need
to be a slave of all these modern and
two capacitors and of all these high
technologists so is this the answer that
the world is waiting for is this the
secret that would bring Tavish Keturah
mirrors and a that is the secret Kotori
provision national that when you press
division Moshe poverty probe is usually
team
attract Madam's that sit into destiny my
impression is that the catastrophe is
not imminent it is that we are already
falling into the address probably we
could give grasp it could hold something
on our way down not not sure I think we
sure we should try to give birth to
ecologically pure creatures and so we
should give birth a new surrounding so
that we shouldn't give birth to children
to babies getting into the same wrong
system so a new birth would mean a new
world that was soft being born into the
new world being born into nature being
born into creative into creative display
of abilities of the dolphins and then
feeling all during all life the well
being linked to this so natural world
complete seamless web of life is what
you come to appreciate if you have this
kind of birth method in the air behalf
yes that is my reputation world is
already at form and a disaster
one has to reverse it primarily to
living through your earlier incarnations
primarily to change one excellent
condition that is the condition inside
the loving mother into another good
ambience litters water and secondly to
have creative intercourse with such
creatures as dolphins so these are the
two keys in Rockledge ever because I lit
a key with us no [ __ ] and it's now
probably much much more much more yes
well thank you very much for talking
with us today
it's very special visitors to when I'm
doing it not that I'm butit engines
gravity with come on we should we should
all of us work and not speak well sir
[Applause]
thanks very much
very interesting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you